[Funny Music]
Man Voice: Have users installed your app?
Wonderful.
Now how your app keeps visiting these users every day
Or from time to time?
We offer you ten effective ways to attract continuous use and interaction
With your app over time.
Users make more than 3 billion searches on Google every day.
These searches may include searching for information
Your app can be made available to users.
When you place your app in the Google index,
Search results can link directly to the content you publish
In your local app.
Adding Android Intents helps your app tell users' devices
Including what your app can do with your device content.
If the user has a great image and wants to publish it,
You can ensure that your app is considered an option when you click Share.
You can also specify the type of web link
Which the application can handle.
Helpful system notifications help Android
On your app to take advantage of it in a timely manner.
You can add key features to your notifications
Do not always rely on remembering users
To run your app.
There is no limit to the extent to which the intelligence of notifications is used
Each user has.
For example, when a user is playing your game
At a certain time every day,
You can tell him at this time what things you might like
Such as access to new levels.
Remind users of the app they have
Using AdWords ads on Google search.
AdWords can remind the user about the key features of your app
And encourage him to try again
As well as his assistance in the implementation of the activity was not
Know that your app can implement it.
Also, you can place a link to a specific placement in the appropriate content
Within the application of the ad directly.
Instead of having to fill in another long form,
You can provide a safe, fast and reliable way to log in
Using their Google Account.
Customize your app
And synchronize the custom user experience on all screens.
Does your app provide users with content through streaming?
You can submit this content to them on the big screen
Using Google's CAF API.
Your phone or tablet will become a remote controller
For your TV or speakers.
The user can view, browse, play, fast forward and listen.
App notifications instantly work on Wear.
And by extending your app to Android Wear
You can add more features,
Such as quick actions and voice control.
You can also set up a great watch screen background for users.
Google Analytics lets you explore
Common application features that you can take advantage of
Which do not work.
Do new users have to search for
Useful features for them?
Users often click on an exclusive ad
And withdraw from your application?
You'll know this through Analytics.
And through Google Tag Management
You can perform an A / B test for application features
Without having to update the application.
Take advantage of Google features
Users' favorites
Which attracts them to the frequency of your application constantly
Including location data from Google Maps,
Sharing on Google+,
Cloud Storage on Google Drive,
Payment of notices, data from the cloud messaging service,
And much more.
Your app can deliver content through features
Other users can get in Android.
Users can add tools from your app
On the home screen or the lock screen.
Daydream also displays content from your app
While sending or placing the user's phone for charging.
For more information about attracting the user
To encourage application use, you can go to the distribution section
In the Android developer site on the web.
And if you want to get more tips on how to improve performance
Your application or game and improve your work in applications,
You can see the videos in the series
Download the "Google Play App Success Secrets" guide.